in the last few videos i showed you
amines and in particular was ethylamine
involved in sn2 reactions but what i
want to show you in this video it
doesn't always have to be an sn2
reaction in fact in this video we'll
look at an sn1 reaction so say i had
some methylamine so let's say it looks
like this so this is our methyl group
bonded to a nitrogen which is bonded to
two hydrogens just like that and has its
lone pair so this is
this is methylamine
this is methylamine right there and
let's say it's in solution let's say
it's in solution with something that
looks like this
let's say
let's say we have something that looks
like this so then we have a
and we have a bromo group now there's a
couple of different ways that you can
name this but maybe the simplest way you
find the longest chain here
it has one two three carbons so that is
a propane so this is a propane
this is a propane and then on the
two carbon regardless of whether you
start counting from here or there so
this is one two three on the two carbon
you have a bromo group and you have a
methyl group right there so this would
be
this would be
two bromo you want to write in
alphabetical order two bromo
two
methyl
two methyl propane what we care about is
what would happen over here
now over here you have a situation where
you have a carbon right here attached to
the bromine and if your brain is really
in sn2 mode you might say hey maybe
these electrons attack this carbon and
then this this electron that's what the
carbon right now gets taken by the
bromine but if you really think about
what the conditions for an sn2 you'll
probably remember that this won't happen
because it's sterically hindered you
have these three other carbons here you
have this these three other carbons here
and actually these are not just carbons
these are ch3s the hydrogens aren't even
drawn but this is a ch3 here this is a
ch3 over here this is a ch3 these things
are going to block the nucleophile's
access to this carbon so you're not
going to see an sn2 reaction here but
what you can see is because this guy is
a tertiary carbon he is bonded to three
other carbons it would actually be a
fairly stable carbocation so what you
could see in step one of this reaction
is just the bromine
just the bromine leaves so if you have
just the bromine leaves then our
situation looks like this
you have a
tertiary carbocation this electron
leaves so it now has a positive charge
right over there that's why it's a
carbocation now and now the bromine has
taken an electron
the bromine it already had one two three
four five six seven valence electrons
one two three four five six seven
and it just took one more electron from
that carbon so it just took one more
electron from that carbon it now has a
negative charge it's now a bromide anion
but now this carbo now that the bromine
is left now now the methylamine can get
involved and this should be methyl
amine right over here so now this as we
learned in the previous video has a
partial negative charge has these extra
electrons it will be attracted to this
carbocation
so let me draw the methylamine
methylamine
so you have the nitrogen
hydrogen
bonded to a methyl group
a methyl group right like that and in an
sn1 reaction that's what this is
remember the rate determining step right
here only involves one of the reactants
that's where the number one comes from
in an sn1 reaction like this the
nucleophile the nucleophile can attack
from either side this no longer is a
tetrahedral shape it's now a triangular
planar shape so it could go in from this
direction or from that direction so in
this case well i'm just going to draw it
in this direction so this nucleophile
this new this nucleophile can give this
electron right here to the carbocation
in which case we will end up with
we will end up with something that looks
like this we have our nitrogen
it has bonded to
two hydrogens over there it has a methyl
group just like that it has this
electron over here now this magenta
electron has been given to this carbon
over there
and then that carbon is bonded to three
other carbons one
two
three and so just like that we have
created element we have to remember
we've given away an electron to this
carbocation the carbocation is not
neutral it gained an electron we wrote
the carbon right there gained electron
it's now neutral but since the nitrogen
gave away an electron it now
has a sorry it now has a positive
it now has a positive charge so what
will we call what will we call this
molecule right over here
now this is a little bit tricky so you
have a methyl group over here it's
definitely well this is no longer amin
it's an ammonium because it has this
positive charge we have four bonds on
the nitrogen so we could call this right
here we could call this n
n
methyl that tells us that the methyl is
bonded to the nitrogen it's not bonded
to the other carbon chain n methyl and
then this right here
these four carbons one two three four
this you could use a tert-butyl group
there's other ways to name it but that's
the most common one so it's n-methyl
tert-butyl
tert-tert-butyl
tert-butyl ammonium
ammonium remember we have that positive
charge there ammonium
ammonium and then we saw in the previous
video this is an ammonium right now but
you had some of your original methyl
methylamine floating around so you had
some of your original methylamine
floating around
you had some of if you have some of your
original methylamine floating around and
this could this could in theory or it
can in practice even nab away one of
these hydrogens or at least the proton
part so it gives its electron to that
hydrogen and then the hydrogen's
electron gets taken
back by what was an ammonium and then if
you have that and this is a reversible
reaction it could go in either direction
it could go in either direction this
methylamine is now methyl ammonium
so it now looks like this it now has
three hydrogens on it right because this
guy bonded with that hydrogen
it now has three hydrogen so this is
methyl ammonium and then this thing over
here
will now look like this lost to hydrogen
so you have a methyl group bonded to an
n
bonded to an h
which is then bonded to a tert-butyl
group
group just like that so now this has
become as i just said this is
methylamonium but this over here is n
methyl
n
methyl once again the n tells us that we
are bonded that this methyl group is
bonded to the nitrogen n methyl tert
tert
and now instead of calling it butyl
ammonium and actually we didn't have to
have this dash over here this was
butylammonium it's now butyl amine
tert-butyl
butyl and then obviously because we have
that nitrogen their butyl amine anyway i
just wanted to show you that that you
know the mechanisms or the reactions i
showed in the last video they're not the
only type of things that can occur you
can also have sn1 and in general it can
act as a as a kind of a well i'd say
it's a it's a it's a a a weak base it's
not a it's definitely not a strong base
but it's it's the most basic of all of
the neutral
functional groups which i said over and
over again so there's many different
types of reactions i've just tried to
give you a sample of a few